ron desantis is just standing up and he
is fighting he had a sit down with the
ceo of disney who was going to slap him
over the wrist and desantis just
completely went on the attack we've got
some video of ron desantis after the ceo
of disney tried to smack him down on
this thing
so here's what i can tell you uh in the
state of florida uh we are not going to
allow them to inject
transgenderism into kindergarten
first graders shouldn't have uh woke
gender ideology imposed in their
curriculums and that is what we're
standing for because we're standing for
the kids and we're standing for the
parents uh and i can tell you this
they're the chance that i am going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights simply because of
fraudulent media narratives or pressure
from woke corporations the chances of
that are zero
when you have companies that have made a
fortune off being family friendly and
catering to families and young kids you
know they should understand
that parents of young kids do not want
this injected into their kids
kindergarten classroom they do not want
their first graders to go and be told
that they can choose an opposite gender
that is not appropriate for those kids
and so if you're family friendly
understand uh the parents who are
actually raising families want to have
their rights respected and i also think
that if you have companies like a disney
that are going to say and criticize
parents rights they're going to
criticize the fact that we don't want
transgenderism and kindergarten and
first grade classrooms if that's the
hill that they're going to die on then
how do they possibly explain
lining their pockets with their
relationship from the communist party of
china and so in florida our policy is
going to be based on the best interest
of florida citizens not on the musing of
global preparation
man you know i've been saying it all
week but every time i play a clip of
desantis it's like you can breathe
freely it's like oh truth truth actually
exists honesty actually exists brave
people actually exist uh sarah i want to
start with you here because i saw
a random person an anonymous person on
twitter this week called you a homophobe
when you were discussing this as far as
i know you're not a homophobe uh but how
great to see someone actually standing
up against this nonsense
yeah dave uh you know it's interesting
because desantis i see this as a native
texan right born and raised in texas
texas is supposed to be known as this
bastion of freedom and liberty and yet
desantis is completely out texas in
texas uh it's so crazy to see his ascent
knowing how far he's come in such a
short amount of time didn't he almost
lose to a meth addict i mean yes it was
like not even a percentage point he was
he almost lost to that guy and he seems
to have repelled almost the entire state
now because i think he's learned what
all of these corporations have not yet
learned which is just because these
people just because these leftists
radicals scream the loudest does not
mean that they represent the majority of
americans we saw it in the governor's
race in virginia we saw it in deep blue
san francisco when they had their school
board members recalled i mean we are
seeing this all across the country
because the leftist radicals are so
radical they don't know anything to do
but double down on this crazy talk like
we should have pornography in schools
imagine fighting for pornography in
schools uh we should we should be
teaching sex to children we should be
teaching them sexual positions these are
things that parents are not going to
stand for and luckily ron desantis knows
that uh and he's certainly fighting for
them i just have to say i understand why
you moved there dave i am very
embarrassed right now as a texan that
ron desantis and florida are leading the
way
uh when it comes to freedom and liberty
and this is just one of the many
examples
listen i never thought that my house
would have to be a refuge for people
from texas but i've got a couple extra
guest rooms you are welcome anytime ian
i appreciate it ian you try at the daily
wire you guys try to honestly assess the
news and give people really what's going
on one of the strange things about this
one is if you read the text of the bill
which we've covered on my show all week
and i'm sure you're covering as well it
has the word gay is not in there this is
completely about being transparent with
what kids are learning at schools and
not hiding what teachers might be
talking about with first graders from
parents are you amazed at just the way
the media gets away with this over and
over again it's just the meme is that
this is the don't say gay bill and this
is somehow all about bigotry and
homophobia
well it's just shameless the way the
entire media literally the entire media
has rallied around the don't say gay
name which is just completely
representative of what the bill actually
does but they do this with almost
everything just the fact that they call
abortion and pro-choice
everything about the left is really just
how they frame certain issues
ticket that if you oppose that issue you
oppose something drastic it's same with
black lives matter the idea that if you
opposed the idea that police were
systemically uh brutal across the
country you were therefore racist you
believe black people didn't matter which
is of course absurd and so i'm not
really shocked that the media is doing
this i'm shocked that people are just so
lazy they don't even google read the
bill all of this stuff is available
online you can just find it gay isn't
mentioned the fact that people are going
around charting gay as if that's going
to undo the evil that is desantis and
his legislation is just ridiculous but
indicative of where we are right now
kyle jumping off that point i've wanted
to have you on the show for a while
because you're one of the guys on
twitter that i follow that is like
you're hitting the media the right way
and trying to expose some of this
nonsense do we need better tactics in
exposing this i mean something did
happen i think this week where it was so
obvious
that that that what they were doing was
so dishonest that i do think we woke up
some people but it's never enough and
it's never fast enough right
yeah well i think there's been a big
shift between the political left and
right and so you have to see if it's out
there he did he sounded like america's
governor he
sounded very much like a concerned dad
on this issue which i think really
worked for him
and
you know it used to be that the populist
left was excited about politicians
standing up to big corporations well ron
desantis has actually done yes not only
in this case with disney but with big
tech remember he signed that bill that
you know google and meta and twitter
can't d platform florida political
candidates or they'll be fined 250 000 a
day uh so i think like he has gotten a
lot of street cred with independence
center right
and no matter how much the mainstream
media squeal at ron desantis right now
he is cutting through the noise with the
statements where he's very
focused and he's speaking to parents and
he's speaking to uh you know just people
who are concerned about what's going on
in the schools and i think we saw that
in virginia you could flip a state
like that so i think that
you know with the with the woke left
they're really in dangerous territory
right now with all of these lies because
i think desantis you know he sounds
very rock steady and sure and i think
people are it's going to resonate with
independents no matter what the
mainstream media says at this point so
i think his leadership is is really
is really
really much needed and it's helping to
cut through the media noise